this is Apple's brand-new 2019 10.2 inch
iPad which retails for 329 dollars and
this is Apple's 2018 11 inch iPad pro
which retails for 799 dollars but seeing
as it's been almost a year since its
release you can now find the iPad pro
for only 674 dollars on Amazon so here's
the question is it worth spending twice
as much cash to get the iPad pro let's
find out there are five major
differences between these two iPads
design performance displays Apple pencil
performance and ports so let's start
with design the budget iPad feels a bit
old with large white bezels all around a
touch ID sensor and classic sham furred
edges the pro on the other hand really
stands out with rounded corners square
edges and black bezels that hide the
face ID system which by the way works
better than you'd expect it's also much
thinner than the regular iPad and after
a year there's still no sign of bending
issues one of the biggest design
differences is that the pro gets two
additional speakers on the top so when
you're in landscape mode let's say
you're watching a video or playing a
game you get true stereo sound which is
a much bigger deal than most people
think the cameras aren't as important
but the pro comes with the seven
megapixel camera on the front instead of
one point two on the basic iPad as well
as a 12 megapixel camera on the back
instead of eight megapixels allowing for
really sharp photos and 4k video
recording at 60 frames per second now
moving on to performance the 2018 ipad
pro's a 12x Bionic chip is still the
best mobile chip ever made even better
than the iPhone 11 pros just released a
13 Bionic chip which is currently the
best smartphone chip ever made the 2019
iPad on the other hand gets the same
8/10 fusion chip as last year's basic
iPad which is pretty disappointing but
is still very capable for basic things
on the plus side it does get above up to
3 gigabytes of RAM instead of last
year's 2 gigabytes but as you can tell
from these benchmarks there's a pretty
massive difference in performance
between both of these iPads now I know
what you're thinking well duh it's twice
the price but
674 dollars the Proust performance is
truly out of this world playing call of
duty mobile the basic iPad experienced a
lot of drop frames at very high graphics
settings so you'll have to turn them
down on the iPad pro you can basically
max it out and turn on all of the extra
graphics settings and have no issues at
all on top of that the stereo speakers
allow you to actually hear footsteps all
around you of course this performance
will also translate over into the
overall feel of the iPad itself and
other professional workflow apps now
let's move on to the display differences
the iPad pro gets pro motion technology
which basically allows it to refresh at
up to 120 Hertz so it feels incredibly
smooth while swiping through the UI and
you can enjoy high refresh rate games
not only that but it can also
dynamically adjust all the way down to
as low as 24 Hertz to match the content
you're viewing so it'll save battery
life as well compared to the basic iPads
display which is always stuck at 60
Hertz and even with the displace off you
can tell that the regular iPad has much
less contrast and it's also much more
reflective as well the pro has a
laminated display which means that the
screen is literally glued on to the
glass the basic iPad doesn't so you can
notice a gap of air under the glass and
above the display this also makes it
feel and sound a bit hollow compared to
the very solid feeling pro the pros
display is quite a bit brighter than the
regular iPads and it also supports p3
wide color gamut so it can display a
wider range of colors like this specific
shade of red that you can't see on the
regular I pad now let's move on to Apple
pencil performance the 2018 iPad pro
supports the second gen pencil which is
$30 more expensive than the first gen
pencil that the basic iPad supports but
it's also a thousand times better thanks
to the new magnetic wireless charging
method the pencil itself has a new
design that feels better in the hand and
it can detect a double tap gesture that
allows you to quickly switch between
tools and yes there are many third-party
apps that support the DoubleTap feature
as well now all of that is nice but the
big difference comes thanks to the pro
motion display technology which
drastically reduces the input lag of the
Apple pencil as you can see
the basic iPad has much more lag and
this is a difference you'll notice daily
not only that but you'll also see a
large visible gap between the pencils
tip and the drawing especially if you're
looking at the display from an angle now
let's move on to the ports the basic
iPad gets a headphone jack while the pro
doesn't this is pretty unfortunate for
some but others might not care that much
the big deal is that the pro comes with
a USB C port which is nice because a lot
of other products use it as well so it's
easy to find a charger when you need one
and another big reason is that you can
do more with the USB C port specifically
transferring files with Apple's new iPad
OS as well as connecting a variety of
external accessories the Lightning port
on the basic iPad is actually very
limited on how much power it can give to
connected devices like storage drives
now before I tell you if you should
spend the extra cash on the pro let me
mention a few more differences the pro
gets the same 18 watt USB see fast
charger that comes with the iPhone 11
pro while the iPad comes with an old 12
watt charger the pro actually weighs
less than the iPad the pro gets
simultaneous dual-band Wi-Fi the pro
gets five microphones instead of just
two the pro gets Bluetooth five instead
of four points you on the iPad and the
pro comes with 64 gigabytes of storage
up to a maximum of once haribhai while
the iPad comes with 32 gigs of storage
up to 128 gigabytes so let's answer the
original question should you spend the
extra three hundred and forty five
dollars on the iPad pro well if you take
drawing seriously buy the iPad pro if
you care about performance for gaming or
other demanding things buy the iPad pro
if you've really care about display or
speaker quality buy the iPad pro if
there's any way possible that you can
gather up an extra three hundred and
forty five dollars to get the best
tablet ever made then buy the iPad pro
the main reason is for future-proofing
three years down the road no matter what
happens to the ipad lineup the 2018 iPad
pro is still going to feel fresh and
modern while the basic iPad is honestly
going to feel old the incredible
performance of the pro as well as the
USB C port will allow the iPad pro to
remain very capable and fresh even after
a couple of years while you might be
tempted to upgrade from the basic
I bet after as little as two especially
if Apple moves over to us BC on the
iPhones next year however if you're
someone who doesn't really care that
much about specs and features and you
just want a basic iPad to do basic
tablet things like using apps playing
casual games watching Netflix and
browsing the web the 2019 10.2 inch iPad
is more than capable enough for all
those things it'll probably be able to
do those same things just fine
two or three years down the line so
honestly those looking for a basic
reliable tablet for basic things should
just buy the regular $329 iPad if this
video helped you make a decision on
which iPad to buy please use our Amazon
links down below to support the channel
and click the circle above to subscribe
for more videos like this one thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
video
[Music]